definitely not starting fast which is a
problem because they're built to
probably play from
ahead um wi with what they got over
there on offense but you know it's been
a rough year for everyone I think it's a
collective whole unit thing on the
offensive side of ball now I've been
tough on Mack early this year but like
he's not you know one play when Mack
makes a good throw the receiver falls
down one play When the receiver's open
the off defens of Line's not protecting
like they're just not compounding good
play after good play let alone just like
doing a regular play you know what I
mean so and then they get into these big
holes and then you throw in
turnovers you know and then you throw
over the Special Teams hasn't been
performing like they have years
past and and then you get this you know
so it's been a tough year it's it's it's
hard to watch I'm sad for everyone over
there because I know the the work that
they put in you know the Matthew Slater
I still he's still on the team he's been
playing forever 15 16 year you know this
got to be tough for him you know it's a
different team there's only a couple of
them from those golden years that you
you you said earlier um so I I I feel
bad I hope that they can stack a couple
good plays together let's just let's
just worry about that before we think
about winning let's just like worry
about like let's stack let's not have a
negative play Let's just not have a
negative play for a drive you know let's
not have a a bonehead penalty that
starts us off in you know first and 15
or you know a holding penalty and then
you're in second and TW or first and 20
and those are Drive Killers we all know
that then you got guys like Von Miller
with their ears pinned ready to just
take your head off like that's you can't
play like that especially how it's being
coached over there so I think think it's
a combination of everything man it's
it's just been a bad year over there and
I feel bad because you know they're
working hard you you you know the stress
is high
because of the standard that's been set
there for the last 20 years you know
there's a standard you know so you just
hope and and and you hope that you know
being an outsider looking looking into
it I'm not I'm not in there anymore you
just hope that the leadership you know
on that on that on on that team can can
get these guys to just worry about the
little things you know because that's
really the game that's that's what the
NFL is it take it's not the team that
you know makes the most plays it's the
team that makes the least amount of
mistakes that wins games are lost in the
National Football League they're not one
like it that's really what it is because
everyone's gonna make a play it's it's
about the play you don't make like in a
bad play that that's what makes a team
win I don't know if you know you know
what I'm talking about B
yeah I know exactly what you're talking
about do so what does the team go from
here do you do you trade M Jones for
Kurt Cousins if if Kurt Cousins if he
removes his no trade clause do you trade
for Kurt Cousins or do you ride it out
with M Jones I would stick it
out you
know they're not GNA pay Kurt next year
you know they're not renting you you'd
rent kurk cousins if you had a
shot you know cuz unless you want to pay
him for the next few years I think you
got to you got to you got to stick with
Mack
and this is where you
see his mental toughness and and you
know when things are not at best a lot
of you know characteristics come out of
people and that's kind of when you want
to evaluate them because that's when you
know you got a dog or not I like M Jones
I like M Jones like I see you can see
you can see the talent like you can see
like why he was a first rounder you can
see like why people are so excited about
Ma just like you said before on this
play the receiver falls down on this
play the defensive end comes free and he
gets sacked and now we're behind the
sticks like it's just one thing after
another but you can see the talent there
with with M Jones I see it on film like
I've seen it on TV it's just you know
it's just this play or that play and it
just it's just sets him back on the
sticks it um it's tough though you know
like for me when people ask me all the
time it's hard for me because I've only
seen really one one way and and you know
the guy that I played with Tom like if
the offensive line was struggling that
day he would adjust his game he would
get the ball out quick let's like find a
quick match up and like you know what I
mean like or if the receiver you know
that he knew how to adjust his game and
it's hard to to give a a true unbiased
take on the whole thing because that's
really all I know you know I I was there
with Cam but that was different you that
was a different year it was weird it was
Co year ain't nobody that Co
year was
weak you know how it goes I was hurt I
was I was hurt the whole I was hurt the
whole year man I I don't that's why I
retired I retired because of
Co I couldn't you couldn't even meet
with people you couldn't eat you were
eating out a little like like take it
take home salads and stuff like what the
is everything was in ever they
started changing up everything I was I
was like I got it was crazy man you had
to test before you came you had to test
before you came in the facility all that
man